steamy salty and Slurpee
ramen this signature Japanese dish is
now an international favorite ramen as
we know it comes from Japan but its
popularity in the country is actually
pretty new no one quite knows exactly
when ramen came to the nation of islands
but one theory is that it was originally
a soup brought by Chinese migrant
workers in the late 19th century and
Japanese folks eventually added their
own unique swag to the cheap and filling
dish and damn we were blessed with ramen
and the dish was a hit with hardworking
Japanese laborers then Japan entered
World War 2 which led to major food
shortages across the country and Rama's
popularity well healers disappeared when
the war ended the us occupied Japan and
imported a whole lot of wheat to the
country leading to more noodle
consumption oh and one reason why there
was so much wheat imported was because
there was fear that food shortages could
lead to communist uprisings after those
really hard times from the 1950s to
1970s Japan went through an economic
boom growing industrialization led to
Rama's popularity as a wholesome meal
for workers a need of something fast
affordable and delicious and busier
lifestyles led to the creation of
instant ramen in the 1950s then in the
1970s the super convenient just add
water quintessential dorm food cup o
noodles was made and it took off like
wildfire in Japan and internationally
but it wasn't until the 1980s that ramen
actually became an iconic part of
Japanese culture today the love for
ramen is real in Japan and what was once
a working man's food is now a widely
loved and devoured dish around the world